JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Well, hello, everybody.
My name's Jonathan Alferness.
I lead up some of our
mobile ads products
at Google, including AdMob.
We're incredibly excited to
be here today at Google I/O
to have the opportunity
to talk to all of you.
A lot of you in the
audience, I'm guessing,
are app developers,
and you've been
through a series of just
enormous changes in this space.
The mobile app business--
heck, the mobile businesses--
aren't even that old.
And yet we constantly
see changes
in how users are interacting
with devices, how they're
engaging in mobile
applications, and it
has a ton of implications
on these businesses
that we're building on
top of these experiences.
We're here today to talk a
little bit about the changes
that we're seeing
in the industry.
The best practices, and
how you can all best take
advantage of these changes,
and the tools and technology
that we're building at Google
across the whole number
of different areas to make
it easier for all of you
as app developers to
find the right users,
to bring them into
your experiences,
to engage those users, and
finally, to monetize them
in the ways that make most
sense for those users,
for your audience.
It's clear that there have
been tremendous changes
in the mobile app economy.
To call it a rapidly
shifting market
is itself an understatement.
In the last 12 to 18 months,
we have seen enormous change
that's brought us from a world
in which most consumers were
either buying paid apps or
downloading free apps that
had ads to a world
in which there's
a lot more complexities.
In fact, the first one
is underscored by users.
The first change is underscored
by users themselves,
because it's the users
in this world that
vote with their thumbs.
They're the ones choosing
the experiences they want.
What we're seeing
now is more than 90%
of the apps being
downloaded are free apps.
These aren't exactly
like the free apps
that were being downloaded
18, 24 months ago.
These are much richer
monetization models
that have ads, yes,
but also have things
like in-app purchase.
I think, as no surprise to
many of you in the audience--
especially any game
developers in the audience--
the second fact is that in-app
revenue has grown enormously.
These are in-app purchases
that help users continue
to play games to download
customizable content
for their experience.
What we're seeing
is a dramatic rise
in in-app purchase across a
whole section of the audience,
across a whole section of users.
Last, and because of
these other changes,
app developers are understanding
that it's not just volume.
The conversation I'd have with
app developers and marketers
18, 24 months ago was one around
how do I drive as many installs
as possible, as
cheaply as possible?
I want volume.
I want to get to the
top of the app charts.
But today, we understand that
the users that you acquire,
the users that you bring into
the experience themselves,
it matters who they are and it
matters what lifetime value.
What are they going
to return to you
in that experience
over the lifetime
that they use your app?
What makes a lot of sense is
that what app developers are
interested in here is ROI.
Look, I'm willing
to pay whatever
it costs to bring in a user, as
long as that user spends more,
returns more to me
in the experience
than I paid for them
in the first place.
There's a lot of
sophistication under here,
but the underlying theme
is that users matter.
The more that we can
pivot around the user
and do the right thing for the
user, the better the experience
we can build, the better the
monetization we can build.
Look, apps are here to stay.
That's why you're all here.
That's one of the
main reasons, one
of the big reasons we
have Google I/O. Apps make
for incredible
gaming experiences
on mobile devices--
fluid, immersive.
I mean, we are talking
the kind of quality gaming
that you had on consoles
not more than two years ago.
Apps make things like messenger
and email clients better.
Apps make all kinds
of experiences,
from retail and e-commerce
types of experiences all the way
through to the more than six,
I don't know, maybe seven apps
I used alone on my way
getting here to Google I/O.
I used Gmail.
I used our messenger client.
Let's see, I used Uber
to get a ride down here.
I used the Google I/O
app itself to figure out
where I was talking
this morning.
And that just names a few.
Apps are clearly here to stay.
We continue to see this
huge growth, not just
in the number of apps,
the number of apps being
downloaded, but
the number of hours
spent by consumers in apps.
The engagement in apps is
going up significantly.
And with that, this
number shouldn't
be too much of a surprise.
We expect $35 billion in app
monetization in 2014 alone.
This massive usage
has consequences.
It's a pretty nice
consequence, $35 billion.
This also drives more
and more competition.
Everybody wants a slice
of this $35 billion pie.
What we're going to talk about
over the next 30 minutes or so
is what all of you can do to
better set up your chances
so that you have as good
a chance as possible,
so that there's a level
playing field to basically vie
for that pie of $35 billion.
What are the challenges
that app developers
face in building business in
this new mobile app economy?
Well, we think that there
are three main challenges.
First, as we talked
about at the beginning,
you need to find the right
users-- the high value,
the high lifetime value users
who will engage in your app
over and over again, who will
return dividends back to you
as a developer.
Not only do you have to find,
identify, and get these users
to download your app, but
you need to engage them.
You've got to excite them.
You want them to continue coming
back to your experience time
and time again.
You want them to engage.
And once you've done
that, once you've
built this virtuous
cycle, you need
to find ways to
monetize those users.
The monetization piece is
undergoing a fundamental change
where it's not just one
monetization solution that
fits all, but it really
depends on who the user is
and what the user is willing
to do in your experience.
Based on that, you should
be presenting the user
with those right
monetization opportunities.
Underlying all of this, we
believe that the more that all
of you embrace a single
unified platform,
the easier all of this
becomes-- the easier it
becomes to track and
understand the value
of your users from
acquisition through retention
to monetization.
The thing that's interesting
is that you are all--
many of you are developers.
You're coders.
You could certainly build
these tools yourself.
But I would argue that
your time, your energy
is better spent creating the
differentiated experiences that
are the apps, that are
what you guys build.
It's your bread and butter.
That's why at Google, we
are working incredibly hard
to build a suite of tools,
of technology that creates
this underlying platform so that
all of you-- large businesses,
small businesses, hundreds of
developers all the way down
to one or two-- can
have an equal chance
to fight for the
monetization, the $35 billion
that we talked about earlier.
Let's break it down.
How do you find the right users?
Well, in the gaming space,
we talk about our high value
users, our engaged
users as whales.
The idea is that it is a
small percentage of users
who engage so highly
and spend through things
like in-app purchase
that they often make up
the vast majority of revenue
that a game developer sees.
But finding these whales,
finding these engaged users,
is often challenging.
At Google, we've been
working across our Adwords
stack-- from search
through display
and YouTube-- to give you tools
so that you can cast the very
wide net across hundreds
of millions of users.
But so that you can identify the
most high-value users for you,
for your experience.
We are giving you tools so
that you can cast that net,
you can find your whales,
and you can bring them
in without becoming
Captain Ahab yourself.
On the search side-- you
heard a little bit of this
from Sundar yesterday--
we are doing a ton
to make app discovery easier
across our entire set of search
products.
Sundar talked about deep linking
in the organic side of search.
We've done a lot to make app
discovery itself a lot easier
in search.
But we've also done a
tremendous amount of work
on the search ad
side of the world.
What you see up here
is a AdWords search ad
for App Install.
This one's for HotelTonight,
a great partner of ours.
What we're doing here
is we're bringing
in insights from Google Play.
We know what users are
doing on Google Play.
We know what they're searching
for when they go and download
HotelTonight, so we're
bringing those same insights
to our search ads advertisers,
our AdWords advertisers,
and we're suggesting
relevant keywords that
will drive not just a
volume of downloads,
but a volume of highly
qualified downloads.
YouTube and video are
a tremendous channel
for growing awareness and for
showcasing to users the really
exciting things about your app.
We see this happening
organically already.
Tons of game
developers are already
leveraging YouTube
as a way to show
to the world what it
is that their app does.
On YouTube, we have this
great advertising channel
known as TrueView, which are
these 30-second pre-rolls that
are shown before videos.
But they put the
user in control.
The user has the ability
to skip the video
if it's not relevant to her.
What we're announcing
now is the ability
to take any TrueView
ad to attach a TrueView
companion for apps so that
those users watching the ad,
watching the video
about your app,
can take action right then,
can engage and download
and install your app from
right within YouTube,
from right within that video.
This is going to be a
great channel because we
have pre-qualified these users.
They know what they're getting
when they download these apps.
Last, but certainly not
least, we have AdMob.
AdMob has been an
incredible channel
for driving app install
for the last few years.
We've driven millions
upon millions of installs
through in-app ads.
We've done a lot of
work here on ad formats.
We've got a lot
more work going on
on the interstitial site of the
world, on video clip download,
but we've also done a
lot of work on targeting.
As I mentioned
earlier, we're bringing
in insights from
Google Play to help
us find the right users
in the AdMob network.
The example we have behind
us-- imagine a developer
who has a photography
or an imaging app.
That developer wants to find
highly qualified users who
will download their app, engage,
and use it time and time again.
I mean, it costs money
to acquire users.
We're bringing in
insights about the users
that we have an Android.
What apps have they
download already?
What apps are those users using?
The example behind me--
we can narrow that down,
that wide audience down to a
set of users who has already
downloaded, installed, and
engaged in various photography
imaging video apps.
We're already seeing
that this is delivering
much higher conversion
rates to advertisers
who are adopting
this technology.
So that's acquisition.
It's easy enough to spend
money or via organically,
find a lot of users,
bring them into your app,
but it's just the
beginning of the story.
The next thing you have to do is
you have to excite those users.
You have to engage them
in your experience.
It's not installs that
matter, but it's really
time spent in your app.
But before you even
get there, oftentimes--
if you think about it from
a funnel perspective--
start at the Play Store.
There are plenty
of opportunities
to increase conversions,
increase your downloads
at the Play Store itself.
This is why we've taken
the powerful visualization
technologies from
Google Analytics.
We've brought them into the
Google Play Developer Console,
and we can now show you what's
happening on the Play Store.
You get to see how many users
looked at your app listing.
If they looked at
the app listing,
did they download the app?
If not, maybe you want to
try some different images?
Maybe you want to try bringing
video to the Play Store
to showcase the app further.
But there's a
particularly scary stat,
because maybe a lot
of users have already
downloaded your app.
But what we know
is that 80% of apps
are download,
installed, and run once.
Just once, and then
they're deleted.
They're never run again.
So re-engagement, bringing
users back to your apps,
is a critically important
piece of this puzzle.
We're doing an awful
lot here, as well.
Again, Sundar talked about some
of the deep linking efforts
that are happening on the
organic side of the world.
We're bringing this
to ads, as well.
The example I have behind me
is for a search ad, for AdWords
advertiser, for HotelTonight.
The idea, the premise,
is very, very simple.
You've flown into San
Francisco, Google I/O,
but strangely, you didn't
have a hotel reservation.
You're an avid HotelTonight fan.
So you search for hotels
San Francisco on Google.
Because HotelTonight
has taken advantage
of the deep linking technology
that we have in AdWords,
they're shown as
the first result.
They're shown as the
top commercial result
for the user's query.
And when the user
clicks on the ad,
not only are they brought
back to the HotelTonight app,
but they're brought back to the
right place in the HotelTonight
app that shows relevant
listings for Union Square in San
Francisco that's only
a half a mile away.
That's a powerful way
to reengage your users
and bring them deeply
back into your experience.
Of course, it works
on AdMob as well.
In this particular
case, you can imagine
a user is in the middle of
some entertaining experience,
and Hulu advertises to
them in interstitial.
Come back.
You're a big Deadbeat fan.
We know that you
have more episodes
to watch in your binge
session of Deadbeat.
When you click
through on the ad,
you're not just brought
into the Hulu application,
but you're brought deep
into the Deadbeat results.
It's just the beginning
of some of the ways
that we're stitching together
not just search and apps,
but really the
web app continuum.
We're also finding more
ways to weave users
through their paths
in apps alone.
You're going to see
a lot more here,
but this is going
to become a mainstay
in how users think about the
experience-- and I think,
and about how all of you think
about bringing users back
to your apps, as well.
Ultimately, it's
about monetization.
You've worked very, very hard
to build a strong audience--
to engage them, excite
them, keep them coming back
time and time again.
But the key piece
is monetization.
How you earn more in this world?
Well, it's getting complicated,
and there's more and more
hybrid models that are growing.
Remember, we've talked a lot
about how it's about the user.
You want to deliver the
right piece of monetization
to the right user
at the right time.
We're going to talk about how
these hybrid models get built
and how you can all leverage
our tools to build them
more easily.
But before we do,
what we thought
we'd do is to break
down the three pieces,
the three atomic
monetization elements as we
see them and talk a little
bit about them in isolation.
First is e-commerce.
Any of the retailers
or merchants
that I have in
the audience today
will know that this has been a
very, very fast-growing segment
of the overall
mobile apps business.
It's taken us a little
while, because early
on in the development
of mobile, we just
threw these complex
forms at our users,
and we expected that
they would pull out
their tiny little devices
and type in their credit card
information, their billing
address, and everything else
to get their $35 ChromeCast.
But that's a lot of work,
that's a lot of friction.
That's where tools like Google
Wallet with Insta-buy come in.
It's a handy set of APIs
that's very, very easy
for any app
developer to plug in.
We take those 20
forms, those 20 fields
that users have to fill in.
And if the user is already
a Google Wallet user,
well then it's just two clicks.
Talk about reducing friction.
It's tools like Google
Wallet Insta-buy that
have continued to
smooth things out,
to reduce friction
for end users,
and have really helped to
grow the e-commerce businesses
in mobile and in
mobile applications.
We've talked a lot so far
about in-app purchase.
Game developers
understand how much value
is available through
in-app purchases.
Again, it's often ways to enable
users to play the game longer.
You've already
got engaged users.
They will generally do this--
to download customization,
extra weapons, cars,
levels-- goodness,
all kinds of different things.
There are tools,
there are technologies
that you can use to show
the right in-app purchase
to the right user
at the right time.
It's critical that you figure
out who those users are.
Because remember, in many
cases, it's fewer than 5%
of users who are
driving more than 90%
of this in-app purchase revenue.
Last but certainly
not least is ads.
Ads have been an incredible
channel for monetizing apps.
AdMob as an ad network
has grown phenomenally
over the last couple of years.
We now serve 200 billion
impressions a month.
We're seen on over 900 million
unique devices in over 600,000
apps on iOS and Android.
And we've paid out more
than a billion dollars
to our developers in the
last couple of years.
But it's just the beginning.
We're really excited about what
we can do with ads in apps.
We've seen a lot on the
banner side of the world,
but we're growing
our inventory, we're
growing our demand in
interstitials, as well.
These are these full
screen ad units.
These full screen ad units
make it much easier for users
to understand what is going,
to understand if they interact,
what they're going to get.
They pre-qualify
users much, much more.
They are easy to dismiss.
They tend to not get
in the way and disrupt
game play, for example,
like banners do.
And they deliver
much, much higher CPMs
to developers, so all of you
as developers can think more
carefully, more
consciously, about when
you show interstitials.
You can reduce the ad
load on your end users
significantly, driving
better user experiences.
As we mentioned
earlier, video is
growing on mobile at
very, very fast rates,
and it's a great
way to monetize.
TrueView has been an
incredible video ad
format for Google
and for YouTube,
and demand for TrueView
has grown significantly
over the last three
or four years.
We're in the process
of bringing TrueView
to our mobile app developers.
It's an interstitial ad format
that puts users in control,
because if they choose
at the ad is irrelevant
for them, after five seconds
they can skip it and get back
to the experience
that they're in.
But true view is great
for app developers,
as well, because it
monetizes even more highly
than what we're seeing
with interstitials.
As we continue to
roll out TrueView,
we think you're all going to be
excited about what it can do,
not just for your
monetization, but what
it can do to keep your
users engaged and interested
in your app.
So we've talked a
lot about the basics,
but what we thought would
really help all of you
was to see this in action.
We're really excited to
have a great partner with us
here today, PicsArt.
Representing PicsArt
is Hovhannes,
who's going to talk
through what they've
done to embrace this mobile
app economy and all the changes
that we've seen.
Hovhannes.
HOVHANNES AVOYAN: Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Hovhannes Avoyan.
I am a CEO and
founder of PicsArt.
We've started PicsArt
in November 2011
with a group of 10 people, and
two and a half years later, we
have a team of IT professionals,
mostly software developers.
What do we do?
We started the company
with the mission
to enable anyone to create
extraordinary works of art out
of ordinary photos
and be discovered
to our network of creatives.
Basically, it's a very
powerful photo editor
integrated with an artistic
photo sharing network.
We built a tremendous community.
We have about a 4.5 star rating
out of 2.5 million people.
The application was installed
over 140 million times
on different platforms,
mostly Android.
We have almost 45 million
montly active users.
We are very proud
of our community.
Why are we here?
Just to tell our
monetization story.
PicsArt is a free application.
We boosted up our business, and
we are profitable right now.
We started with advertisement
as a single-revenue opportunity
for us.
A couple of months
ago, we started
implementing in-app purchase.
In-app purchase is
very important for us
because it's allowed us to
diversify our revenue stream,
but also, it provides
better experience
for our premium customers.
Now, we are about split
between in-app purchase
and advertisement, which 20% is
coming out of in-app purchase.
It's one of the growing
segments for us.
We personally believe we
can be even more successful.
What do we need for that?
We really need good analytics.
We need the analytics
which help us to understand
who are our users, what they
do with our application,
how our application performs.
With all that knowledge, we want
to apply different monetization
strategies to different
kinds of users.
We really hope that
partnering with AdMob
and having all
these new features
will help us to reach the goal.
Thank you very much.
We are excited to
be an AdMob partner.
Back to you.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Thank you, Hovhannes.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: I
think that's a particularly
compelling example.
But I think what
matters to all of you
is actually how this happens in
practice-- what we've provided
for tools and technology to
make all of this as easy for you
as it can be.
And for that, I am thrilled
to bring up my good friend
and colleague, Babak
Pahlavan, who leads up
our Google Analytics products.
He's going to walk you
through this in detail.
Babak.
BABAK PAHLAVAN:
Thank you, Jonathan.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Good afternoon.
We have a lot of
folks in the audience.
Good afternoon to our
folks on livestream.
Let's talk about monetization.
As most of you guys know,
earlier in the year,
we announced the deep
integration of Google Analytics
with AdMob.
Together, the integration
between Play, AdMob, and GA,
we are offering a
unified platform
that's job is to focus on
optimizing your monetization
strategy by really
focusing on your users.
One unified dashboard inside
AdMob that would actually
help you to monetize,
promote, and analyze.
The thing that we're
going to talk about today,
specifically, is around
how to further apply
the same philosophy
that we all have--
by focusing on your users, we
can build much better apps.
That something that
we all understand.
If I focus on building
apps that are really
tailored to my users,
engagement would just go higher,
and I'd end up actually
building more delightful apps,
and everyone is happier.
How about applying
the same philosophy
on our monetization strategy--
focusing on your users
to better monetize?
Specifically, there's
a lot of techniques
that are happening in industry.
But as we all know, the
[INAUDIBLE] is on the rise.
As Hovhannes actually
mentioned, in-app purchase
is becoming the tool of
choice to better monetize
your products.
In general, for
a lot of us, when
we talk about
monetizing our products,
the high level categorizes
our users into two buckets.
You have casual users that
download the products,
they use it a little bit.
You also have then
some of these guys,
they become engaged users.
They become your frequent users.
How do we monetize?
Normally, a lot of us,
we just use ad networks,
we use AdMob and other
places, to place an ad
in front of our casual users.
But for engaged users, we are
looking for something better.
They would actually
want something
that would enhance
the experience.
A lot of us use IAP to
sell them, the next eagle,
the next soccer,
football, or something.
That's a high level story.
As we look at it, a lot of
our highly sophisticated
developers, they end up
using a lot of the systems
that we offer to really
tailor their in-app purchase
campaigns, but on users.
It's become sort of
difficult to use,
and you have to have a
lot of developers in house
to pull that off.
What we really want
to do is to not only
make in-app purchase
better and more optimized,
not just for bigger
guys, but for everybody.
We want to democratize access
to this technology for all.
Let's go through an example,
so that we can actually
clarify the specific
that we're launching.
I'm an app developer.
I come to my AdMob's
main homepage.
This is the main AdMob Home tab.
I can see the lay of the land.
I get to see how
much earnings I have,
my revenue conversions, and
also sessions and engagements.
We have two demo apps
that we are using.
These are real apps
that we've developed.
They're in the Play Store, but
they use it for testing a lot.
They're real, but it's our
zero, as you can imagine.
I have two apps here.
I have Color Drips
and I have GameFans.
They're doing sort of
well, but if I look deeper,
Color Drips-- even though
the ads earnings for this one
is higher, the total earnings
a lot less than GameFans.
I wonder why.
I look deeper, and
realize that even though I
have in-app purchase
enabled in both,
this one is not doing as
well as the other one.
I only can see 23
transactions that
are happening on Color Drips.
I wonder why.
I wonder what's
really happening here.
When I look at my app, I have
an interstitial ad running here.
It's a good looking ad.
There's nothing wrong with it.
But the challenge
is that all my users
see the same ad, and the same
ad format and everything.
I'm sure the ad network is
a good job of optimizing
this as much as possible.
But ultimately, all my
users are seeing this one ad
campaign for my in-app purchase.
I wonder if we can do better.
Let's analyze this.
I come back to AdMob.
I click on the Analyze tab.
Then I come to the Audience
section and our locations.
I understand globally what's
happening with my users--
where is everybody?
As I look at this
a little deeper,
I notice that my
Brazilian users, they
tend to be more engaged
with the product,
and they tend to buy something
from the in-app purchase
campaign.
That's an immediate
insight that I
wouldn't have had
if I didn't use
Google Analytics inside AdMob.
That's one insight that's born.
I can see that Brazilian
users are engaged,
and they tend to buy something.
I wonder if it has something
to do with the fact
that everyone is in
Brazil, and they're
taking a lot of good photos of
the soccer games, or football,
as we call it.
Let's see if I can actually
build a monetization campaign
exclusively focused
on these folks.
Notice on the left
hand side, there
is a new option, a new
menu that we're enabling.
It's called Audience Builder.
If I click on that,
my hypothesis this--
if I can actually
build a campaign that
shows a difference
IAP purchase ad
to my engaged Brazilian
users-- if I could do that,
my hypothesis is
that I'm going to be
able to actually
earn more money.
That's the goal that
Jonathan was talking about.
We all want to earn more money.
We want to monetize better,
but at the same time,
we don't want to
sacrifice user experience.
When I click on
Audience Builder,
this brings up GA's powerful
segmentation builder.
For those of you guys that
are GA users on the web,
you're familiar with this.
But this is now the
tailored version
of this, exclusively
on mobile apps.
It's incredibly powerful.
In fact, this is offering
250 plus dimensions,
and it can build 20
combinations of these.
Now the math nerd in me wants
to know what's that number,
what's the permutation
count to that?
It turns out it's
actually 4 to the power
47 different permutations
you can create.
I've been told that's more
than the number of starts
we have in our known
universe, or more
than the number of sounds
that we have on planet Earth.
But of course, we want to
give you back to power.
The point is this is incredibly
powerful segmentation builder.
I'm going to run
through an example
so you can see what it is
that we're talking about.
By dimensions, of course,
I mean age, location,
differently behavior
metrics, such as time
on app, language,
and yadda yadda.
Let's go through this.
Let's build an audience list.
I come back here.
I click on Behavior, and I see
that it says Session Duration.
I want to focus on
users that are spending
at least 10 minutes with my app.
So I put down 600 seconds in the
Session Builder, click on Save,
then I come back
to the demographic,
then I can see that there's
a Location option down there.
I can just come down
and type in Brazil.
Brazil gets typed,
and I press on Save,
and as soon as the clicker
moves, we're running.
Now what I've done
is I'm almost there.
I've actually created a
segment, an audience list,
that says only
focus on users, only
find me users that spend at
least 10 minutes on the product
and that come from Brazil.
I'll give it a name.
I'll call it Brazil, highly
engaged users, and off I go.
Now I have an audience list.
Now I come back to my
normal business as usual
with AdMob, the
Great Promote tab.
I click on that, and I
can create a new campaign.
I choose my creative elements,
then I come back here.
There is a new option that
is getting enabled, called
Audience.
I can click on Audience, and
lo and behold, my Brazilian,
highly engaged users
should be there.
The audience list
that we just created.
I add that to my audience list.
And notice you can create
all kinds of permutations.
You can create all kinds
of different rules,
and add different lists
on the one campaign,
or you can create multiple
campaigns with multiple lists.
The power is in your hands.
I click on Save, and
I click on Continue.
What's really happening here?
It used to be that all
my users would just
see this one interstitial ad.
Now, users-- using
this new campaign
that I'm running-- users
are coming from Brazil,
but are also engaged.
They've spent at least 10
minutes with the product.
They're going to see
something different.
They're going to see an IAP
campaign that's exclusively
focused on them.
Just imagine how many
different campaigns
you can try out,
how much power is
now back in your guys' hands.
It's not difficult.
It's super easy to use.
Again, we wanted to make
sure to democratize access
to this technology to everybody.
Key takeaways--
Google is working
on building an integrated,
cross-platform,
very easy system
to ultimately help
you developers more successful.
We are committed to making
you guys more successful.
As we announced
earlier in the year,
deep integration of GA within
AdMob is the first step.
We have a lot more work
to do, we understand,
but we are committing real
resources behind this effort.
Second takeaway here
is it's imperative
that you spend time
understanding your users,
not just to tailor your
app, but also to tailor
your monetization campaigns.
It ends up paying
off significantly.
Third, with Google
Analytics inside of AdMob,
you have an immense
amount of power
to really understand your users.
But now, more and
more, take advantage
of all the
technologies that we're
enabling inside GA for apps to
really tailor your monetization
campaigns.
Make sense?
One last thing I wanted to
actually talk to you guys
about, if this slide
loads-- there's
a lot that we're doing
across Google for mobile apps
developers, and we're trying
to consolidate the knowledge
base for this.
You have a MOOC-- you
have a Massive Open Online
Course that we offer
at Google Analytics.
It's going to go live in August.
This one's going to
be exclusively focused
on mobile apps.
Make sure you sign up for that.
We're going to talk about
the best practices, the best
strategies that you can learn
in order to be successful.
Last time, we ran the
MOOC on levels general GA.
We had 135,000 people who
signed up, and 35,000 graduated.
We expect the same sort of
turnout for this one, as well.
Yeah, that's on that.
That's the link for this,
for Analytics Academy
with Google.com.
For those that haven't
signed up for AdMob, go ahead
and sign up with
AdMob, and you get
to have access to all the great
stuff we just talked about
over the next couple months.
Thank you so much,
and that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BABAK PAHLAVAN: I think
we have about 10 minutes
for a few questions.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: We
have time for question,
but we're also happy to
just take them individually
if you guys want to
come up front later.
Any questions that
you guys want to ask
in part of the broader audience?
BABAK PAHLAVAN:
Also, we're going
to have office hours
at 3:30, by the way.
So Google Analytics and AdMob.
We're going to be
on the second floor.
We're going to be answering
questions one by one.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Our
developers, our teams
down there helping you
guys, but yeah, go ahead.
Question.
Everything that we
talked about today,
essentially all of
the announcements,
are things that are either
out now-- so the AdMob Google
Analytics integration,
for example,
is something that you can go
download and play with today.
Or things that are rolling
out in the next quarter.
BABAK PAHLAVAN: Specifically
the Audience Builder
we were talking
about, so that one's
going to be available
sometime in Q3.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Questions?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Should the
targeting tools be automatic?
Do you want to--?
BABAK PAHLAVAN: Yeah,
that's a good question.
The question was shouldn't
these things be automatic?
Absolutely, we believe in that.
There are two modes to this.
One is that a lot of developers
actually want to have control.
They're the ones that
they know the users,
and they want to
segment, they want
to build some of the campaigns
that are highly optimized
the way they think about it.
They set up the rules, and then
the rest of it is automated.
However, in fact, on GA,
we announced something
that we call a Smart List.
This is for general web
marketing campaigns.
That allows you,
now-- we actually
pick the right set of users
automatically for you.
I can imagine the same
sort of technology
is going to make its way
to app developers, as well.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
I'll be a blend.
We will try to do as
much of this for you
as we can, automatically
through experiments and testing,
et cetera.
But you will always be able to
find some set of insights that
automated machines can't.
We encourage you guys to take
a look at the data yourselves
and try to ferret out those
valuable opportunities, too.
Yeah, go ahead.
Sorry, let me take-- there's
a question at the mic first,
and then I'll come back to
the gentleman in the hat.
So from the mic, first.
AUDIENCE: Are you guys
looking at doing anything
with native ad formats?
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Absolutely.
We've been working hard
at AdMob across a bunch
of our different channels to
find the right native solutions
to bring to bear.
We're experimenting with a
number of different varieties
right now to find what works
best integrated into apps.
I don't have anything
for general availability
to announce just yet.
We can maybe chat
briefly after this.
But my expectation is that
in the next quarter or two,
we'll have a general
availability beta.
Thank you.
That's a good question.
Now to the gentleman
in the hat, and then
I'll come back to the mics.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: AB
testing in the Play Store.
BABAK PAHLAVAN: Yes.
There's a number of
efforts on that front.
The question was, are
we going to enable
AB testing
experimentation for apps?
In fact, you can do that right
now using Google Tag Manager.
If you use GTM for
mobile apps, we actually
enable you to do AB
testing for mobile apps.
Not just on Android, but
also on iOS, as well.
You're going to see us
integrating these things
further and further
inside the app,
so integration becomes seamless.
I know that the Play team is
looking at that, actually,
to enable different
strategies all together.
You raise a very good point.
Do I know if paid works
better, or free works better,
or [INAUDIBLE] work better?
You can imagine
that we're working
toward enabling you guys
to really figure that out.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Back to the mic.
AUDIENCE: Are you guys planning
to add more transparency
in terms of the search terms,
how people are actually
discovering your apps
on the Play Store?
Because right now, it's
a complete black box.
You don't really
know whether you
get discovered by featuring,
by search terms, et cetera.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
It's a good question,
and you're not alone
in asking the question.
We don't have anything to
announce there specifically.
I think the thing
that is closest
is in bringing those insights
over AdWords so that search
advertisers can leverage
some of the same key words,
so that might be a
bit of a round robin
approach to gaining
some of those insights.
We'll make sure the Play Store
team keeps hearing the feedback
and thinks about providing
that form of analytics.
BABAK PAHLAVAN:
Because it makes sense,
your question makes sense.
AUDIENCE: It is there on
the web for years already.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: And I don't
really understand
why it's not there
in the Play Store.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
My guess is it's
nothing more than
prioritization and getting it
to the top of the stacks.
So that's why we'll
lean on them when
we give it back
to Mountain View.
Thank you.
Other questions?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Yeah, absolutely.
So we have house
ad support in AdMob
that allows you
to take advantage
of exactly what
you're talking about.
If you have a number of apps
that you deliver, and you have
AdMob in all of those apps,
you can set up house campaigns
to cross promote
to your other apps,
and you can actually
yield manage that
across some of your
house campaigns,
as well as your
third party demand.
What we're starting to talk
about with Google Analytics
integration is that
you can do much
more sophisticated segmentation
and decision engine type
logic to figure out
who gets what, as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Yep.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: It's free.
It's your inventory, right.
You're just giving up additional
monetization opportunities
to show your own ad, to show
your own cross promotion.
Yeah.
Make sure you stop
by the office hours
if you'd like that are
starting just in a few minutes.
They'll walk you through
what you need to do there.
BABAK PAHLAVAN: But imagine
with this new capability,
you can actually now-- I mean,
ultimately, monetization,
we're not concerned about.
We want to create the best
experience for the users,
and then if you end up actually
promoting different apps
we download using
Play Store, so there's
monetization for
us from that angle.
Not necessarily on
the app side, but--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Look,
many of our customers
are already doing this,
so it's a great thing
to take advantage of.
Other questions?
I see another one at the mic.
AUDIENCE: So this deep linking
solution that was announced,
is that specific for
Android only, right?
It's not available on iOS?
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
It is currently
an Android-only offering.
We're looking deeply at what
we need to do on the iOS side.
I don't know this off
the top of my head.
No, it is Android only right
now, it's a great question.
We'll let you guys know when
we have a solution for iOS,
as well.
BABAK PAHLAVAN: Something to
call out, actually, on this.
Our objective is to create
the cross-platform solution.
We understand that
app developers would
like to be-- when
you're an app developer,
you want all the different
platforms, right?
You're not Android
exclusive a lot of times.
Because it's Google, you
have a lot more access,
you have a lot more freedom,
you have a lot more acceleration
that you can deploy.
But then we're always interested
to work with other platforms,
because once again, we
believe that's the only way
you guys can
successful altogether.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: We're
running low on time.
Why don't we wrap up.
If you guys have
additional questions,
you'll find us up front.
Thank you guys, again.
BABAK PAHLAVAN:
Thank you so much.